de premier adjoint au maire à têtes de
listes pour ce scrutin municipal à one
le gall a choisi de présenter sa propre
équipe on mord pas bien une candidature
où l'on retrouve d'anciens membres de la
majorité municipale sylvestre dognin lui
aussi adjoint au maire nathalie
bellegarde et à gâteaux des il y a dans
la vie des séparations des mariages
forcés il ya un certain nombre de choses
qui peuvent se passer
nous avons décidé avec mort pas
autrement et l'ensemble de l'équipe de
porter un vrai projet évidemment qu'il
ya une réflexion sur la tête de liste
une réflexion sur le programme une liste
composée d'étudiants des chefs
d'entreprise de retraités et de
financiers au programme de cette équipe
les entreprises la sécurité la
démocratie participative et
l'environnement faire des propositions
pour la commune avec des coûts
financiers maîtrisé voilà ça c'est un
axe important n'est pas question d'aller
partir de partir sur des projets
démesurés pour que les impôts et la
fiscalité démord pas y un s'enflamme
nous on voudrait faire un bilan carbone
déjà de la commune enfin en tout cas des
actions communales de la ville de savoir
si on est bien on n'est pas bien avec
nos véhicules avec la mobilité des
agents avec notre rupture
la structure municipale qui est la
mairie quatre listes seront donc
présents dans les bureaux de vote le 15
mars face à erwan le gall le maire
sortant grégory gare et astier et les
conseillers municipaux d'opposition
ismaila vannes et michel chapa